every business has five parts and only
five parts every business
creates something of value they attract
the attention of people who might be
interested in that thing which is
marketing
they sell that offer to people who want
to buy it which is sales
they deliver what they've promised to
their paying customers which is value
delivery
and then there's finance you look at all
the money flowing out you look at all
the money flowing in
and you answer two very important
questions a is more money flowing and
then flowing out if not you have a
problem
and b is it enough is it enough to make
all of this time and effort and stress
and frustration
worth it
i um this i need to put a disclaimer out
before we get started
usually the camera is not right up to my
face if you're watching on youtube you
will be able to see this
this is the first horizontal cast that
i've done since
uh my achilles repair recovery um so my
foot is currently all the way over there
in the air uh and i'm back here but
we're making it work or aren't you
fragile
and uh today we are celebrating the
10-year
anniversary of the personal mba man how
does that feel
it feels great it feels surreal
like uh i remember writing the first
draft of the book and it doesn't feel
like 10 years ago
but it's it's been really gratifying to
see uh
how much people all over the world have
enjoyed it and found it useful and uh
it's always an interesting experience
going back and editing things that you
wrote 10 years ago
um so so the past year and a half two
years that i've been working on this
project has has been very interesting
from
from a personal time capsule uh
standpoint uh my my
my writing has changed my my thoughts uh
about us a lot of things have changed so
it was it was great to be able to
to revisit this particular work and and
really update it for 2020 and beyond
have you when you go back through things
have you found that much
about your thinking has has changed have
you got you sort of
curling your toes a couple of little
bits here and then you think oh my god
why did josh 10 years ago think that
the the thinking overall i'm happy to
say is still really solid
uh i used a lot of adverbs 10 years ago
and i
i don't know why i will have to go back
into my word document and figure out how
many adverbs i deleted
and it is it is in the the probably
mid thousands uh
so so just like you know i think as a
beginning right this is something that i
think beginning writers do a lot
you want to emphasize the things that
you're emphasizing
in your head as you write and the way to
add that emphasis
is you know adverbs or italics or you
know
exclamation points getting really
excited and and so for me
it was like being able to take a step
back and say
okay you can get a get this point across
far more effectively
by being clear and simple and concise in
your language
and let the construction of the
sentences do the work instead of
trying to underline and bullet point
everything in the manuscript so i think
that's a really good principle manner i
think part of it's probably to do with
maybe confidence of getting a little bit
older
you know like having the the um
belief in the hope that the audience is
is there for what you're writing as
opposed to needing to give it the bells
and whistles and
and embellish it and i think as well as
part of getting older you just realize
people have you know you have a finite
number of books that you can read
even if you're like 16 you have a finite
number of books that you read and as you
get older you need to be more and more
selective so therefore if you can get
the point across in fewer words then i
think
you've uh you've definitely done a good
a good second pass there
so my main question upon reading the
intro
to the personal mba you will have some
strong thoughts about business school
and uh sort of business degrees in
general did i need
to spend five years at university and
get two degrees to be able to run my
business
probably not no um i i think
there there are many things to be said
about
about universities and degrees in
general um i
i think the the fairest universal thing
to say
is that the vast majority of people in
the world can benefit by learning a lot
more about business
and in order to do that you don't
necessarily have to
quit your job go back to school borrow a
bunch of money spend a lot of time
the essentials of business are very
clear
and very straightforward and relatively
few in the grand scheme of things
and so spending some dedicated time
learning
what those fundamental principles are
how they work why they're important
that's a great use of time for pretty
much everybody
the the
set of people who are well served by
existing business schools is relatively
small and i think if if your primary
goal
is to start a business work
independently
um be in control of your destiny you're
far better by
starting your business on your own and
skipping the debt part
and investing all of that into the
actual business
uh then then going to school and and
having both the time investment but then
also
the financial investment having to
recover that over the course of your
career
um ends up being a pretty big weight for
a lot of people
yeah well i mean me and my business
partners sat next to each other in our
first ever seminar
so i started operating my business from
essentially the
the exact same types like the starter
pistol was fired on university and on
becoming an entrepreneur
on the same day and um man i did a
three-year bachelor degree with one year
in industry and then a master's in
international marketing
i just all i saw was this massive
bifurcation
between what i was learning in class and
what i was experiencing in practice in
the particular industry that i went into
go
saw me gave me a broad cross-section hr
marketing accounting b2b b2c like course
everything everything and i was like i
am sick what do i need to know
henry ford's scientific model of
management for like why do i need to
understand about
kaizen and laissez-faire like autocratic
management styles and stuff like this
it felt so archaic and maybe it's been
updated
a little bit like there wasn't even a
module on social media when i was there
um so it might have caught up a little
bit but something
something tells me that it hasn't so
what do you learn typical
formal mba what do you learn
so the a lot of the formal mba is
about mbas make some assumptions about
what you're going to do
when you get out right you're you're
going to be
the ceo of a retail
or manufacturing operation you're going
to go into corporate finance
or you might go on to be a cfa or a cpa
um in certain circumstances i mean or
now it's
hedge fund manager is is the the
big kind of newer entry since i went
through
um which doesn't capture what a lot of
business people
hope for their careers right now um
there's there's much more of a focus on
entrepreneurship and independence
starting your own thing
running your business on your own terms
um that that
some of the classic things that are
taught in business school like for
example
uh michael porter's five forces
very useful from a corporate large you
know
fortune 50 corporate strategy standpoint
if you're starting a new business from
scratch you don't have to think very
much about
porter's five forces there are 5 000
other things that will be more useful
for you to start with
so and and i don't know about you but
the the thing that struck me
because i i did a business undergrad as
well um it was a five-year program that
had
uh an extended internship component
which
which i thought was the most useful part
of the whole thing
operating in industry teaches you a lot
uh but the thing that struck me on the
academic side of things
was that there was never an attempt to
define
what businesses are or how they work
in like the the grand when we say we're
doing business
what is it exactly that we're trying to
do here
having some organizing theory around
what this is how it works why it's
important
how to do it better would be very useful
and and
business academia is still extremely
siloed so
the finance professors teach the finance
stuff the operations folks teach the
operation stuff
and there's very little attempt to try
to bring that all together
into a cohesive understanding of what it
is we're trying to do here
and what does it look like when we're
doing it well
man i uh i felt that very very harshly
that the the synthesizing
of all of these different points of view
were just totally
totally totally absent so what are the
fundamental principles
that underpin being an effective
business operator
yeah there's um this is this is funny
i um i'm kind of flabbergasted that i'm
the person who wrote this book
because when i started the project i was
looking for a book like this that was
probably written by a business school
professor
50 or 60 years ago and it just as far as
i could tell it just
didn't exist so the whole genesis of the
project is like well this is important
it doesn't exist yet so let's here we go
let's make one
um so the way that i organize
business knowledge is is around a
framework called the
the five parts of every business and
it's it's really
uh an attempt to define exactly what
businesses are
and what businesses do regardless of
industry
market organization size regardless
every business has five parts and only
five parts every
business creates something of value they
attract the attention of people who
might be interested in that thing
which is marketing they sell
that offer to people who want to buy it
which is sales they deliver what they've
promised to their paying customers
which is value delivery and then there's
finance
you look at all the money flowing out
you look at all the money flowing in
and you answer two very important
questions a is more money flowing and
then flowing out
if not you have a problem and b
is it enough is it enough to make all of
this
time and effort and stress and
frustration worth it
and that's really it like every business
from the largest fortune
500 to the smallest like just getting
started in your garage workshop
kind of venture every single business
operates in that flow with the same set
of problems with the same set of
questions with the same
set of criteria on is this working or
not
the scale might be very different but
the fundamentals are
exactly the same so to me that's where
you start
business is this the set of five things
that you must do
if one of them is missing it's not a
business
it's a hobby or a non-profit
or a flop or a scam or a bust
like that's you can't get rid of any of
them
and and so using that as the fundamental
organizing principle
behind this is what we're doing when
we're doing business
you you get all sorts of wonderfulness
out of that so first of all
for each of those concepts or for each
of those stages of the business
there are really only 30
on average concepts that are really
important to understand in each of those
areas
and so it's it's very straightforward
to say okay i'm trying to attract
attention and gather interest in
in what it is that i've made how do i go
about doing that
and so understanding the fundamental
principles of
of attention and demonstration
and you know all of the things that
allow businesses to attract attention
and make people interested
understanding that small handful lets
you do that job way better
than you would be able to do if you
didn't understand those things
so the the whole organizing concept of
the personal mba is okay
here's what we're doing here's the small
set of things that you need to
understand
to do that well and then by
understanding those
you can be in a practical business
situation
or or have a practical problem say
this reminds me of something that i
learned and you pull the concept and use
it in the situation in which it's
designed to be used
i love the beautiful simplicity man and
having the feedback from the real world
you know having stuff that is um
emergent bottom up rather than kind of
dictatorial top down
just seems we're not if you were a
businessman you are not here to armchair
philosophize
about what is the best way to run a
business like there are
ugly businesses out there people that do
like sewage
removal and like you know that create
nuts and bolts and stuff like that
they just need to know what works so if
it's as simple as you've made out there
why do people over complicate
business so much why
why do they overestimate how complex
business is
perhaps would be a better question i
think there are a couple of different
reasons
um i think a charitable way of putting
it
is there are a lot of people who operate
in business
who want to be seen
as smart and sophisticated
insiders and so they tend to
use large fancy words and
explain things with a great deal more
complexity than they actually require
um here's here's a good example um from
from the book
in marketing i talk about uh branding
which is a word that's thrown around
way way too much um and and people
people will wax philosophical for years
if you let them about the value of
branding the importance of branding what
makes a good brand all of that stuff
if you reduce that very complex can to
an
outsider seem um like this
impenetrable thing that experts know how
to do
and uh people who don't have experience
don't know how to do
um if you reduce that to reputation
and you do things that will likely
result in you
increasing or earning a good reputation
and you stop doing things that will
probably decrease that reputation
you are 98 of the way there to branding
the rest of it is graphic design um
so it's just like i
i think there's this this tendency with
people like
they just want to seem smart and special
and i think all of us as business people
you know whether we're on the corporate
side or whether
we're starting our own things there's a
lot of value to be gained
in simplicity and straightforwardness of
thinking
um not dressing up the ideas making them
sound um sound more complex than they
actually are
um i think that's that's really that's a
hallmark of
sophistication and intelligence when you
can look at a situation and find the
simplicity in it
and ignore all of the things that are
mostly distractions and don't add a lot
of value
i think sadly business is not the only
industry which is cursed
with this particular proclivity of of
people right it is the mark of a
charlatan
to explain a simple thing in a complex
way it is the mark of a genius to
explain a complex thing in a simple way
and it's pervasive across absolutely
everything
you know it got me thinking there you
were talking i can't remember tyron
woodley
come to me ufc champion x ufc
uh want to say middleweight champion and
he had this philosophy about his
fighting
which was if you win nothing else
matters
like his argument is that if you are
successful at the
end result of the thing that you are
supposed to do everything that came
before
doesn't mean [ __ ] he wasn't big into
sort of smack talking and he kind of
he's all right with the press but he
just
sort of cracks on and he's maybe his
fighting style isn't like the most
exciting but he was he just dominated
people and it's the same with this
it's like it doesn't need the bells and
the whistles
and you're adding friction into your own
system
which is giving all of your competitors
an advantage you don't decide to do that
by using the crazy terms or by having 20
meetings a month about
about the the graphic design and the
branding and stuff like that
here's the story here's a story for you
man so um bruce stuckworth the
co-founder of turnerduckwith the graphic
design company
they were the people they were the
people that made the amazon smile logo
oh nice
um so late 1990s amazon's just breaking
out of making
of selling books they're starting to do
all other stuff
and they go to bruce and his his
partners and he sat down with jeff bezos
who at the time he's not
richest man on the planet but he's like
still he's still pretty big time
anyway they put across to him the a to z
the smile with the little arrow and
there's like loads of clever stuff going
on when you actually
i didn't realize it was an a to z that
arrow goes from a to z and that other
bits and pieces
and uh jeff's sat down and he
says ah i love it bruce brilliant
fantastic
and he's got his jeff's got his cronies
with him and they say right brilliant
should we start we'll start
split testing we'll focus group it and
jeff's like no no no no
we don't we don't need to do that like
it's fine and they're like
jeff it's it's we're quite a big company
this is a
this is a large decision for you to make
off the back of a whim
like we really and they sort of pushed
back against him and jeff turned around
apparently in the meeting and said
anyone who doesn't like that logo
doesn't like puppies
and that was it yeah that's the level of
non-bullshittery
that you want to get your business to
yeah and when you think about it
another you know corporate branding
uh graphic design sort of thing you know
fedex
is very famous for the arrow that's in
in the shape which which is cool
if you notice it but if you had to gauge
on on a scale of 0 to 100
is the success of fedex because they
have a little hidden arrow in their logo
or because they can get a package from
point a to point b overnight wherever it
is in the world
what do you choose like they could just
spell their name and it would be fine
um so yeah it's it there's there's an
enormous amount of
value and power in being able to look at
a business or a business situation
and identify very quickly what are the
things that are going to be most
important
what is going to determine success or
failure in this instance
and what are all of the things that you
can just afford to
ignore or not pay attention to how much
of success in business
is that elimination
um quite a bit and i i would say that um
in conjunction with something else
that's really important
um which is experimentation um so you
see
businesses that tend to succeed over a
long period of time
have a process of continually trying new
things
gathering data about what works and what
doesn't
and they keep doing the things that work
and they stop doing the things that
don't
um so i think amazon is a great example
of this in in terms of the large company
culture
um and and smaller businesses do this
all the time
if if you are responsible for putting
food on your table
and you are doing a bunch of things that
aren't
uh attracting attention or closing sales
to get revenue in the bank account so
you can pay your own paycheck
that's a problem and and so you see
particularly early stage businesses that
do really well
they avoid making dumb mistakes so
betting the
the farm on something that
is in reality an experiment
but they just don't have good data yet
and so
avoiding avoiding
mistakes or decisions betting everything
on something that's not tested
but you also see them testing a lot of
different things
and then gathering data about what works
and what doesn't and then shifting
resources towards the things that
do indeed work i suppose that's a
massive
advantage we often hear about
diseconomies of scale you know the
increased friction in having to
communicate
between 45 different area managers and
flights and you know all the other
endless emails
but that's a perfect example of real
economy
of scale the fact that you just have so
many resources
endless computer space you know like
bottomless pits of money
that you can continue just everyone
wants to work for you because
your ability to talent recruit is super
high so yeah i
am i think it's it's nice to see
the diseconomies of scale kind of being
battled back i got
i was quite fatalistic about um scaling
up businesses for a little while and
then
thankfully companies like google and and
facebook and
amazon that have a flexible approach to
a large size business i think have
really
really changed that so in your
experience what are the most common
errors
that you see people making by the new
businessman or established ones
um okay one of them is related to what
you just said
um which is a concept in the book um in
the people section
so the the book is structured three uh
three primary parts
business people and systems and so when
you think about it
businesses are created by people
to serve other people for the benefit of
people
so understanding human psychology and
how people work that's
that's a really important thing to know
and so
in um in the working with people chapter
there's a concept called communication
overhead and you can think of it
in in terms of for every person that you
need to communicate with
on a day-to-day basis to do your job
the larger that group becomes the higher
and higher and higher percentage
of your time and energy is spent
communicating sharing information among
the group of people that you're working
with
not necessarily working on value
creation marketing sales value delivery
and finance
and so that's a very real cost um
i don't know if you've ever worked in a
large corporate environment
um i worked i worked for a fortune 50
company huge cpg company
global procter gamble for seven years
and uh a good dramatic example of this
is that uh i was responsible for
uh measuring the effectiveness of online
advertising
for png's brands online uh
with with all the the advertising that
they were doing on the internet
this was new so so i was trying to
figure out all right you know we're
spending x million dollars a year
in banner advertisements on the home
page of msn.com
uh does does that work and
in that role i was responsible for
talking with probably 30 or 40 people
who had a stake in what this looked like
when it was done
and when the project was done i went
back and looked at my schedule
i spent three solid months
just talking to people trying to get
them on the same page
to create a proposal of what this
might look like after we do a pilot run
and so there's there's a certain amount
of like yeah in a big company
you have all of these resources you have
potentially millions of dollars you have
very smart people to work with
and yet when the group becomes so big
people spend most of their time
communicating with each other
and not necessarily pushing the work
forward
in a way that actually creates value and
so one of the advantages that small
companies have
and one of the reasons that i chose to
leave the corporate world and do my own
thing
is your communication overhead goes way
way down
if it's just you or a team of two or
three
uh the research says that up to about
eight
in terms of a team who is uh that is
dedicated to do a specific thing
is ideal because every additional team
member
adds capacity but the group never
becomes
so large that you're spending more time
and energy on communication and
coordination versus actually
doing the work the team is ostensibly
responsible for completing
does that make sense that's the uh
business equivalent of dunbar's number
absolutely so can you get them around
a normal sized office table
if you can't you know like those rough
the roof like diet guides it's like
well you should be looking to eat around
about a handful it's like you don't need
to measure it it's like just
get a business table if everyone can sit
around it great if they can't
maybe a bit big i we've brought up
amazon a couple times in our discussion
i think their internal way of describing
this concept
if if i'm getting it right is two pizza
teams
like if you need to order two pizzas to
to have like a late night business
meeting
if you if you get beyond that threshold
you're too big you need to split this
team into different groups
i love it um it's a it's a nice way of
visualizing the
the same thing yeah i love it so okay
what are the what are the common errors
so we've got this kind of um
i guess the the diseconomy of scale or
just general inefficiency in terms of
friction
excessive meetings too much too much
back and forth what else what are some
other common errors
um so i would say not enough
experimentation uh which we've talked
about
previously um there's there's an example
um one of the new concepts in the the
10th anniversary edition of the book
is called um exploration and
exploitation
and so this comes from a famous study
in decision theory and computer science
which is um i would have to preface
this i do not condone gambling in any
way shape or form
but this is the example that they use in
the research literature so this is
this is the example that i'll use
imagine you walk into a casino
and there's a row of slot machines in
front of you
you don't have to pay money to play the
only cost that you pay is your time
so you go up there's this row of
machines and your job
one of those machines pays out way more
than the others do
but you have no idea which one so the
research question
is what is the process that you use
to figure out that best option in the
world of all of the options that you
could take
and the the
the insight is fascinating so
when you start with no information the
first
strategy is pretty clear you just play
machines at random
and you collect some data from the world
about what's giving you a good result
and what's giving you
a less good result and then over time
you shift
more and more in the direction of doing
the thing that you know gives you a good
result
consistently so you know as a percentage
of your time
your your highest option becomes more
and more and more
of your total decisions made or
time and energy invested but and this is
a
critical part the optimal strategy is
never to choose what you think is the
best option
and do that 100 of the time
the best option is to always
devote a certain percentage of your time
to experimenting and gathering
information because there's a very real
possibility that you get into what's
usually called in statistics for
analysis
a local maxima right by a fluke of
statistics
one option looks like it's the best but
it's not the best in the grand scheme
of all of the options you have at your
disposal so
always dedicating a certain amount of
your time to exploration
to trying new things gathering new data
seeing what works
is absolutely critical it's critical if
you
are a massive company who is very
comfortable
selling the products that you've always
sold um
it's critical if you're just starting
something new and you're not sure of all
the things that you could offer to
customers
which would have the highest uptake or
or have the highest profitability
i think most people don't think about
experimentation enough
as both a learning strategy but also a
how to maintain your competitive edge
over a long period of time
strategy it's the same fundamental
process
and it gets you both of those rewards so
that makes it really important
that's um the interesting thing there
from a game theoretical perspective
is it's not just you playing the slot
machines
there's actually a bunch of competitors
who are all in
maybe not playing your slot machines but
they've got like um the floor above and
the floor below and all of the slot
machines are all like linked in together
somehow
and they might stumble up across the
slot machine which actually pays out
jackpot
it's it's like you're writing my book
like on this conversation
um there's another concept in the book
called the hidden benefits of
competition which is exactly that
um most people view competition as a bad
thing
and this is this is particularly a
beginning entrepreneur's classic mistake
of you have this brilliant idea
for a business that's going to be
awesome and then you go to google
and you type it in and you're like oh
man someone's
doing this already i can't do it now
this is terrible um so
having competition is a wonderful thing
from multiple
perspectives the first is that
it's kind of in the explore exploit
framework
it's like you get to watch other people
play this game and you get to notice
what does well
and what doesn't without spending your
own time and energy and resources
playing the game is a much faster way of
collecting information from observing
the world around you
and gathering knowledge and data from
that the other thing
which is really important particularly
for beginning entrepreneurs to
understand
if people aren't interested in spending
money
on what you have to offer there is
absolutely no possible way that your
business will work
uh this is an idea called the iron law
of the market
if there is not a market of people who
are willing to pull out their wallet
checkbook or credit card and say
yes please i'll take one you're screwed
like there's
nothing you can do and so the nice thing
about having competition
is it is a 100 guarantee that you're on
the right side of the iron law of the
market
you know people are spending money
you're watching them do it
and so if you're looking at all of these
different options and you have a choice
between
uh an offer where there is a clear
established group of people who are
spending money
or a completely green field that you
think is new to the world
uh bet on the one where people are
spending money that's probably a higher
percentage bet for you
i think the the cliche quote is
idea is the constant execution is the
multiplier
and there's that yes that teal quote
which is any idiot can learn by
experience i prefer to learn by the
experience of others
yes absolutely yeah i think the the uh
multiplier thing came from
derek sivers right it's like yeah
a awesome idea with mediocre
uh or non-existent execution is maybe
worth
ten dollars but an awesome idea with
awesome execution with an awesome market
can be worth billions um so yeah it it
and it really helped this this is where
particularly for people who are new to
business
it helps to have a solid understanding
of what it is you're trying to do and
how it works
because the the number of people who
will
um start a business without thinking
once about the market
or doing any sort of market research is
astounding
uh the number of people who will put
together an offer
and not do math about if this offer is
financially sustainable
is huge and and so just having um
the the the term of art for this sort of
thing
is is a mental model a mental
representation of what a business is
what its parts are how it works how they
interact with people
um in the same way that people have a
mental model of how it is you drive a
car
and what's supposed to happen when you
step on the gas pedal and what's not
supposed to happen
when you step on on the the brake you
get a sense very quickly of like
something unexpected happens this is bad
for me i should do something right away
uh we're just trying to do the same
thing for business like
understand what it is understand what
you should be seeing or noticing about
um about what it is you're trying to do
and that allows you to make
very quick and very accurate
valuable decisions in the moment about
what you should
either start doing or stop doing here's
something that me
and every friend i know that is an
entrepreneur young entrepreneur has come
up against i want to hear your thoughts
on this whether your experience has been
similar
we had for the first
five to ten years of running our
business an absolutely
irrational fear of raising the price i
was
terrified of raising the price so i
would say
as another little heuristic people to
watch out that is new to business
you can probably raise the price more
frequently than you think especially if
you've got demand
yeah i'm curious to hear from from your
perspective
um looking back on it why
your price was low in the first place
and what caused you to raise it but what
was that experience for you
so i run club nights and we had a
particular discounted entry before 11
o'clock on our saturday
and we were rammed beyond belief
like so crazy busy we totally cornered
the market
but me and my business partner felt that
our success was on such a knife
edge it's a particular quirk of our
industry that it is very
fickle very fast moving um it occurs on
a weekly cadence
as well so you've got like week after
week after week
which is kind of performance and you're
always obsessing over
this week versus last week numbers
revenue top line bottom line stuff like
that
very unique sort of um industry to be in
and um
we had this stupidly low price but that
was what we thought had got a success
and i remember we were talking about
putting it up from 2 pound 50 to 3
pounds
to get into like the big biggest best
club night in the city
and i remember the night before
sleepless night
because i was adamant that that was
going to be the beginning of the
avalanche that would snowball to topple
the company
like right yeah that 50 pence man that
that
that fifth that's it you know we're
gonna we're gonna do it and i'm like
absolutely crap in my pants
whereas now me and my business partner
having sort of
swallowed the very very large red pill
we needed to to understand that
we're more than happy when we see the
demand like basic economics
what do you do when demand out strips
supply like
the fundamentals and yeah i've got
two uh co-hosts on the show johnny and
yousef that all of the listeners will be
familiar with
and they were doing diet and training
plans personalized diet and training
plans
for like 35 pounds and it would take
them hours
hours and hours and hours and they were
terrified and i'd gone through this
situation and i was saying boys
that that plan's worth like 100 or 200
pounds
oh no and they had to swallow the fear
as well is this something you see
elsewhere is it just a quirk of the
north of england
abs no this is this is an absolute
universal thing
every entrepreneur experiences it and a
lot of it a lot of the time it comes
from
from feelings of insecurity right you
don't know if people are gonna like what
you're offering
um rejection feels really big and scary
and most of us
given the option would prefer to avoid
it and so
we think that the best way to get people
to like what we're offering
and take us up on the deal is to make
sure that the price is
so low that it would be objectionable to
no one and so
i think the rule of thumb um i've done
uh consulting and advising for many
years
and the rule of thumb for beginning
entrepreneurs is take the price that
feels like
the gut obvious this is where i should
start
triple it and you're almost in the
ballpark no way of where you should
start yeah it's and it
it's taken me in some instances a lot of
persistence and persuasion to get people
to test it
um i'm curious in your experience did
you did you see
um or what happened to demand when you
raised
went up yeah why do you think that is
uh this is a really important thing to
understand
so i could argue that maybe people use
price as an indicator of quality
that there's a little bit of price
signaling going on
um there was some other externalities
that were happening like we just
had the market and we were doing well us
having more money allowed us to reinvest
more money which made the product better
which meant that we were more
competitive
we could spend more money on marketing
it also meant that
we didn't obsess so much over time on
the accounts which meant that we spent
less time on the back end and more time
on the front end
driving revenue um driving uh doing
things that drove revenue rather than
obsessing over how much we had
um it's just raising the price
is such a wonderful feeling because it's
the thing that you were doing yesterday
but more money for you
right nothing else changes
is a good thing because you're right you
can reinvest in marketing you can have
a a better quality value delivery
process
you're stressed less so you don't have
to to count your pennies and you can
invest that time and energy and making
the offer better
one of the things that that i expanded
quite a bit
in the new edition of the book is what
you mentioned first was the
the status issue social status is a
a huge ingrained part of the human brain
over millions of years of development
and uh understanding social status
dynamics
particularly social status dynamics
with respect to price
opens up a lot of opportunities that
aren't necessarily
intuitive before you learn that
relationship
so tangible example um
a rolex does not tell
time better than a timex it actually
tells time worse it's not as good at the
thing that a watch is supposed to do
but that's not the point the point
is it is expensive it is visible
it is exclusive it sends a signal to
other people
about intangible or what would otherwise
be
intangible qualities of the person who
is wearing the watch
that's the value and that's the reason
why people are
willing to spend frankly way too much
money
on on something that in the grand scheme
of things is not super important
it's because of that social signaling
component
and so in in the economics literature um
this is called a veblen
good veblen was an economist and veblen
goods
you know bringing up supply and demand
earlier
veblen goods are the exception to that
very familiar
pricing curve because for status
signaling goods demand goes up when
price goes up
they're the ones which is just that
that's the industry that you want to be
in man
super weird that's the yacht that's the
yacht and the retire at 35
industry that's where we want to be yeah
it's um
that will have been turned up to 11 as
well given
social media we're all self branders
the uh transparency of what we do with
our money and how we spend our lives is
now
in itself a shop window for other people
to watch
yes yes and you you get the
performative aspects of social media
specifically because of social status
it's it's not
let me inform people of an accurate
representation of what my day
looks like it's how do i construct and
broadcast an
image that makes me look good in front
of other people that i care about
it's it's a very very different way of
thinking which
is beneficial in two ways uh the first
is that from a business perspective
if you think explicitly about social
status
status signals quality signals all of
those things
they're legitimate ways to make your
offer better and more attractive to more
people
you can improve and offer a great deal
just by thinking a little bit about
when people buy this or when people use
this how does it influence how they are
perceived by the people around them that
they care about
the other thing is for you as
as a decision maker both as an
individual and as a business person
you can get so much mileage about
thinking about status considerations
from the other angle
just for a second of like am i buying
this because it's going to be effective
or am i buying this because i really
want to look good
um classic entrepreneur example waste of
time at the beginning
uh stressing about logos and business
cards
zero percent correlation with the
success of your business
absolutely zero but it feels
like this really critical thing that you
need to put a lot of thought and care
and attention to because
this is how you're representing your new
position in society your new
responsibilities your new
how you stack up with regard to
everybody else and so
understanding this on the personal level
can help you
it saves an enormous amount of time and
energy because you can
kind of defuse the things of like yeah i
don't need to be spending time working
on this stuff right now i'm going to pay
attention to the things that actually
matter
there's a quote from a daniel
schmacktenberger episode who i did
with a little while ago and he says the
more i reflect on the biological
predispositions that arise the less i am
controlled by them
yes and yeah oh my god if that isn't
true you
dude like i like i say i've run
nightclubs for 14 years now
the popping bottles let's spend a grand
on vodka that the five people
sat around the table can drink like a
quarter of
uh the glass is more expensive than the
liquid inside of it i actually had a
sociologist a
lady called ashley mia's on you might
like a book it's called uh
vip she did uh ethnographic research
i'll send you the i'll send you
everything over once again um
she uh she became a party girl
and followed the biggest promoters
around la and miami for six months
as part of her like ethnographic
research for this
into status signaling uh and and um
what's it called
high or waste we call that waste
signaling or something like that
basically you buy something
where people can see that you couldn't
even drink that much you couldn't even
eat that much
like you don't even it's the 75-car
garage that people know you can't even
drive those cars once per week per year
like that's that's why here's something
the person element of business is really
really what fascinates me
the question i had for you was whether
you think someone's performance
in business is a projection of their
personality
and whether there's a point where
business development is limited by a
lack of self-development
i think that yes that is broadly true
that i think the more you develop
yourself
and your skills and your abilities in
the areas
called the economically valuable areas
of business
value creation marketing sales value
delivery finance the better you are at
those things or some sub
subset right so the nice part about
larger companies
is you can have specialists in those
areas instead of having to do
all five of them yourself so i think
it's true that the
the more skilled you are in
those five things the more successful
you're going to be
i think successful is important to
qualify because successful is
doing something that you enjoy in a way
that
pays the bills for you um that is not
entirely draining and allows you to live
whatever the definition of a good life
is for you
um so a tangible example here
i have quite a few friends in industry
um very successful at building companies
um
their revenue is between 10 or 100 x
mine
um they they are in the you know 50 to
multiple hundreds
of employees category and i've had a
real good up close look
at the inside of their business and what
their life looks like
running the business and if i tried to
do
what they're doing i would be miserable
every minute
of every day for the rest of my life or
or however long i ran this business
it is not for me and so i think
there's a there's a very underrated part
the personal side of business
is deciding what kind of life you want
to live
what kind of work is rewarding to you
how do you want to spend your time who
do you want to spend it with
and for me success in business is
getting closer and closer to that ideal
of
you're doing what you like with people
you like
on projects that are interesting and
and on the other side of things
eliminating stress
or eliminating worries or eliminating
lower value less
things you care less about in favor of
the things that you care
intensely about and so you know i i
think business in particular
because there
is a numerical figure attached to it
right how much did your business bring
in this year how many employees do you
have
how many millions of dollars of venture
capital did did you raise in your a
round you know there's in getting back
into the status consideration
there's there's the gamesmanship that
goes on in terms of
you know well you know it's not a it's
not enough to have a a
company that got or earned a hundred
million dollars in profit
this year if the company over there got
101 million dollars in profit that way
of thinking in the absolute
is absolutely nuts um
so i i think it's really important and
the best thing that you can do for
yourself
is be very very clear in defining
what it is you're trying to do and why
what's important to you and what's not
and then just it gets back to the
experimentation bit
notice what's happening around you as
you make decisions
in your business or in your career and
notice when you're getting
closer to that ideal or or when you make
decisions that gets you further away
from what you want
i think especially if you are someone
who's sort of
classically working class who's grown up
perhaps in a household
which is work is a labor
work is something that you have to do
not get to do
um right you can carry that puritan work
ethic over quite easily
into operating a business i certainly
found myself doing that i wonder whether
or
not
you you see that quite typically oh
absolutely um i've seen it in my own
life
so so good example is um
i remember the day when i told
my father that i was going to quit my
job
at big company to start my own thing
and so for background uh dad was a
elementary uh school teacher and then
a uh a principal of small farm town
uh school northern ohio in the united
states
and straight out of college
i made as much maybe a little bit more
in my big company job than he had made
in his you know 25 30 year career at
that point
so from his perspective
what are you doing like you have this
amazing
job um it's it's only upside from here
why would you throw away the secure
thing in order to chase something that
may not be as good and the answer to
that
for me was that the environment that i
wanted to work in
the types of projects i wanted to do and
the latitude that i wanted to have
over my own day-to-day life and
decisions
was not compatible with the large
company job
and so even if it paid less in the short
term
i was willing to trade this sure thing
for a chance at maybe getting closer to
something that would be more ideal for
me
and in retrospect it was the best
decision i ever made
because had i not done that thing
um i would not have been able to
experiment my way into something that
worked
in in a really wonderful fashion i think
a lot of people
particularly people who like me i didn't
have a business background growing up
i grew and grew up in a small town
um my conception of business was that
there were
places where people went to draw a
paycheck like i knew
i i didn't understand anything about it
and i think if you don't
if you come from a working-class
background um or
there are a lot of folks who grow up in
rural rural environments and don't
have the day-to-day exposure of what
this kind of life looks like
um it can be really challenging to break
away
from those conceptions of what you're
supposed to do
or how things are supposed to work in
favor of
an uncertain experiment that
feels like it may turn out well or may
turn out not so well
the nice part about it is that in terms
of
building a business that gathers enough
income
to support yourself in a comfortable
fashion
that is way way way more accessible
than most people assume it is if you
don't come from a background where
people do this
on in a common basis there's a
strategy in pickup artistry called you
are the prize
and it basically uh suggests
that as you step into the frame with the
person
that you're trying to speak to that you
should come from a place of abundance
not a place of scarcity
and yes that as a strategy for business
is so so useful
because it stops the neuroticism of
what-ifs
what if i make this jump to something
that i i know i love but might not
succeed
and i lose the secure thing that's
behind me well
you already got the secure thing that's
behind you you'll probably just get it
again
or maybe even the thing you wanted won't
happen but you'll get a better secure
thing
around the corner or whatever it might
be
i think far too far too many people
have such pervasive imposter syndrome
that it
it sort of secures them it glues them to
the spot
and remembering that imposter syndrome
really can only
smash itself up against the success of
your reality
so many times before it's not
imposter syndrome anymore it's more like
an addiction it's more like a thought
addiction that you've got on your side
where
you're just not prepared to give
yourself the credit that you're due it's
like look go for it man
like go and do the thing go and do the
thing and if it doesn't work
you will make something else work you've
got this far you've got the talents the
skills that you've got the passions that
you've got whatever it might be
and if anyone's got any reservations
about that
realize how scary it is for you to think
about doing that
and realize that not only are you
competing with everyone with your
potentially superior skill set
but that by making the decision that is
the separating factor
by deciding that you do the thing
you are in the top one percent
regardless of skill regardless of
experience regardless of background all
of that stuff
you're in the top one percent by making
the leap
and the reason that you can tell that
that's the truth is how terrifically
like us bendingly terrifying it appeals
to you right now
absolutely there's there's another
similar trick
in the same vein that that i have gotten
a lot of mileage out of and highly
recommend
um and it comes to to making requests of
people
um very relevant to our our previous
conversation on
pricing uh so
let's say you're you
do what i recommend which is triple your
price
and see how it goes uh the the per the
the first thing that people will say is
like oh no
no nobody's going to sign up for that
nobody's going to pay me that there's no
possible way
the mental trick is make
other people tell you no don't
assume the rejection before the
rejection actually happens
make the request and if they're going to
say no to it
make them tell you no and just that's
that shift of okay this might not work
but i'm going to make the ask and i'm
going to get the data
before i decide whether this is a good
idea or not um
it it prevents an enormous amount of
self-rejection or or closing off
potentially viable worthwhile lines of
experimentation and inquiry because you
didn't have the courage
to make the offer and just see
if that was something that would work or
or wouldn't
so you know this this um very often
comes up
in a less entrepreneurial more more job
um job context of
looking at looking at a job posting and
be like
oh i they would never hire me for that
like i don't have
five years of experience in some weird
technology they're asking for or i don't
have any
i haven't worked in this field before
whatever uh no apply to the job anyway
make them tell you no um
wanting to get a promotion wanting to um
start a business and and make an offer
to see if it works
just having that mindset of
i'm not going to assume that people
don't want this or this doesn't work for
other people
i am going to try it
if it doesn't work okay i got data
that's useful
but very often it does and and you're
absolutely right you have to put
yourself out there and
actually ask or do the thing
to get that accurate data otherwise
you're just assuming something is
a fact about the world that may not
necessarily be accurate
being comfortable with the rejection is
a power
a superpower being able to take it and
not feel like your ego is being
destroyed
and just taking out what it is well
maybe at the wrong time maybe it was the
wrong price maybe they've already got a
insurance provider computer systems
manufacturer whatever it might be
like it's a it's a good way to be
anti-fragile
josh man yeah i uh i've loved today it's
been absolutely absolutely awesome
super fun hanging out um thank you so
much for having me on this has been fun
yeah it's been great man so the personal
mba the 10th
anniversary edition will be linked in
the show notes below
where else do you want to send people
any of the stuff that they should check
out of yours online
yeah so so two things um so the personal
mba
website personalmba.com um you can find
a list of all the key terms in the book
you can find a recommended reading list
so all of the business books i recommend
if you want to go deeper in any of these
topics they're all cited referenced on
there
um and then uh trying to take my own
advice
i am constantly doing uh research and
experimentation in all sorts of
different topics
and so if you're interested in more of
the r d
side of me joshkoffman.net is
is my website you can find a lot more
about my other research
in learning and skill acquisition uh
research into
uncertainty and change and some of the
more philosophical
um practical side of ambition is
probably a good way to
to put it um you can find all of my
other books at joshkoffman.net
josh i have to get you back on for that
one i might have to have the uh batman
alter ego i've had bruce wayne
and now we need a batman on him we can
do we can do another one
i am happy to hang out anytime brother
awesome thank you so much for your time